after working for a long time in SQL
domain moving to Big Data was a great
challenge for me but by upskilling
myself I conquered the challenge and
today I'm a certified Big Data engineer
now I can easily carry out my big data
projects as well as successfully lead a
team of Engineers I even got a decent
salary hike
hi I am Assad Shah from Canada and I
recently had to kill myself with the
professional certification program in
data engineering offered I simply
learned in collaboration with Purdue
University
I've been working in the I.T industry
for 17 plus years now
and I'm currently working as a tech lead
in the data engineering projects my core
experience lies in SQL Server that's why
I'm moving to Big Data was a challenge
for me when I started my new job as a
big data engineer I realized that I
needed to upgrade my skills to improve
my performance in my current role so I
chose to upskill myself and I couldn't
have made a better decision after
completing this course I am now well
versed in Big Data engineering after the
professional guidance I received from
Simply learn the course curriculum is
well formulated while industrial
relevant Concepts and project
which helped increase deeper knowledge
about Big Data moreover the courses in
collaboration with Purdue University
which has a great Alumni network and
Industry experts as instructions how
made The Learning Experience even better
my goal is to work as a project manager
on Big Data projects and after the
certification I can surely achieve it in
the coming years with simply Zone I
could make the change from an SQL to the
Big Data domain and this learning is
definitely going to add a lot of value
to my career journey ahead whenever I
get the time after my busy schedule I
love to go on to long drives for my wife
I also enjoy cooking whenever I get a
chance
the wall is moving at a much faster Pace
than we think make sure you don't leave
behind so obstacle yourself and move to
a step forward and step closer to your
dreams